so last week in the wall street journal
there was a kind of remarkable op-ed
stating as clearly as anyone has ever
stated
the nature of the threat that we face
from china the op-ed was written by
someone who would know
the director of national intelligence
john ratcliffe
he called the communist party of china
quote the greatest threat to democracy
and freedom worldwide since world war
ii it's an amazing piece worth your time
if you haven't read it
just a moment we'll have director
radcliffe on to discuss that
he wrote this quote the intelligence is
clear beijing intends to dominate the
united states and the rest of the planet
economically
militarily and technologically i call
its approach
of economic espionage rob replicate and
replace
china robs u.s companies of their
intellectual property replicates the
technology
and then replaces the u.s firms in the
global marketplace
now those aren't simply legal disputes
they have actual consequences
for millions of american workers on our
standard of living
and what your kids will do for a living
ratcliffe noted that in 2018 a chinese
wind turbine manufacturer ripped off
trade seekers from a massachusetts-based
infrastructure company
called american semiconductor as a
direct result of that
theft american semiconductor lost over a
billion dollars in value
and had to cut 700 jobs that didn't
happen because the company american
semiconductor was careless
it happened because they were the victim
of theft
that's happening everywhere including in
the pentagon
according to ratcliffe quote china also
steals sensitive u.s defense technology
to fuel
president xi jinping's aggressive plan
to make china the world's foremost
military power
us intelligence shows that china has
even conducted human testing
on members of the people's liberation
army in the hope of developing soldiers
with
biologically enhanced capabilities there
are no
ethical boundaries to beijing's pursuit
of power
remarkable we know where this is leading
and ratcliff's op-ed spells it out
quote beijing is preparing for an
open-ended period of confrontation with
the united states
washington should also be prepared
leaders must work across partisan
divides to understand the threat
speak about it openly and take action to
address it
john ratcliffe is the director of
national intelligence the man with more
intelligence
before him than anyone on the globe
apart from the president we're happy to
have him on tonight
director thanks so much for coming on
tucker good job
you spelled this out so clearly
that it made me wonder why the rest of
us so many in our public life haven't
been saying this for quite some time you
make it sound obvious
well i think you did a good job of
encapsulating why tucker
um there are a lot of people who for
economic reasons
don't want china to be our greatest
threat there are a lot of people who for
political reasons
don't want china to be our greatest
threat in america but the intelligence
doesn't lie
china is our greatest threat and it's
not even close
no other country has the capability of
essentially taking away the american
dream
and a specific plan to do so and the
intelligence
is clear so tucker i wanted to use the
unique vantage point that i have
to make sure you know as the director of
national intelligence my job is to
warn the american people of threats and
there is no greater threat
than china to america the most jarring
part of the piece
i thought was your description of
the massive ramp up of the chinese
military
and from your telling not necessarily
for defensive purposes
what do you think their aim is
well again dominate militarily
technologically
and economically on the military front
they've already achieved having the
largest
uh navy of any country in the world
from a military force standpoint there
are the people's republic of china has a
military of 2 million
they want them to be the largest and
they also want them to be the strongest
which is why they're engaged in
what you reference which is called gene
editing literally trying to alter the
dna
experimenting on dna to make soldiers
sailors and airmen uh stronger and more
powerful
that's horrifying do you think
beijing anticipates some kind of
physical confrontation with the united
states in
in the next several years
well here's the funny thing um tucker is
china knows at this point that the
united states is still the world's
superpower they know they're catching us
in all of those respects
they're banking on the fact that we're
not going to do anything until
they're superior in all those respects
you know great generals always say
it's better to fight downhill right now
the united states
can fight downhill against china we
don't ever want to be in a position
where we're looking up at china and
all of the plans that they have all of
the initiatives made in china the
digital silk road
belton road initiative those are all
thin veneers and facades
for which china is going around the
world
and essentially gaining the influence
power
to become the world superpower and
supplant the united states in that role
we heard a lot over the past four years
about russia's ability to
break into john podesta's gmail account
to the extent you can't
the extent it's not classified give us a
sense of china's penetration
into our networks government networks
well it's significant and growing every
day and tucker you made a great point in
your opening about russia listen they're
they're
you know uh they are a a dangerous
adversary i don't mean to minimize them
but you made the point correctly about
economically russia can't compete the
way china can the largest economy in the
world is the united states
the second largest is china russia is
not in the top ten
italy brazil and the state of texas have
a larger economy than russia so
as dangerous as russia can be they
cannot compete with us the way china
is and china has a very specific plan to
do that
and one of the ways that china has made
their way to the top is they understand
that information is the key to their
dominance so they're going to get there
any way they possibly can that's what
subsidizing huawei and zte is all about
those are chinese companies that are run
by the chinese government
they know that they can steal more
information if they run the
telecommunications networks over which
our information travels
that's one of the ways that china has
gotten so good
in terms of getting into our networks
and into our information society
we've been asleep thank you for helping
to wake people up john ratcliffe
director of national intelligence great
to be with you tucker thanks
next time you hear someone describe
russia or turkey or iran
is the greatest threat we face laugh in
their face